OK now, exam one.
I mentioned this before.
I thought this would
be helpful to everyone.
What I did is put together
what I call a concept map.
And I will post this,
here it is, oh, there
is a periodic table,
isn't that lovely?
This is what I put
together for you guys.
And I call it exam
one concept map.
Now, I'm not going
to go through it now.
But I wanted you guys to
have the big picture of what
we've done.
This really is a
celebration, especially when
you look at all of the
things that we've learned
and how they're all
connected together.
And that's what I
wanted you guys to see.
OK so, look at this.
So here are on the
left here are--
this is all not graded stuff,
here's what's been graded.
Oh, and this is what's
graded on Monday,
exam one problem topics.
Look at all those things.
Now over here, we have
the three goody bags
that you guys have had.
And there have been
problems in there.
And here we have the
problems that you've
had from the textbooks
and the topics there.
Here we've had your
seven recitations.
Here you've had--
it's even color coded.
It's even color coded.
So here you've got the lectures.
So these the nine lectures
and all the topics
that we've talked about.
Today is number 10.
And as I said, I will
tell you something today
about Lewis structures that
will not be on the exam,
and that is resonant
Lewis structures.
So we'll teach that.
And then those are
the three quizzes.
Now you notice,
there's some things,
like here, OK, we've covered
this stuff, like Lewis dots,
and electronegativity,
Lewis structures,
stuff like that we've covered
that has not been on a quiz.
But it could be on the exam.
So this is a concept
map that I hope
gives you a sense of how
this all connects together.
And how this connects
together to give you
the knowledge that you
need to answer questions
about these topics.
Now, the exam is not--
these exams walk the balance.
We want you to learn how
to solve these problems.
What I want you to do on
Monday is run out of knowledge,
not run out of time.
Did I get a--
thank you.
Now, you might run out
of both, but listen--
[LAUGHTER]
But these are not meant to
break you in a speed test.
These are meant to see if you
have learned the concepts.
So what I ask you to do on this
exam is show us what you know.
As you may know already, I am
a big fan of partial credit.
Lots of partial credit.
If you show me you know
something, you will get credit.
And so that gets into,
also, exam strategies,
but a lot of you already
know about this stuff.
But please remember,
don't just go in order,
and then run out
of time, and not
even see the last two questions.
Take a look.
Tell me what you know.
Show us what you know.
We're not about the last
decimal on some calculation.
I'm much more about do you
understand the concept?
Do you know how to
solve this problem?
So show us that,
please, on the exam.
OK, now was that another
loud snap in favor.
I think that means it's
like positive reinforcement.
Topics, OK so, the other thing
I want to say about the exam
is we're going to connect
concepts together sometimes.
That's the point.
Exams aren't just going to be
another three quizzes plus one
more question on Lewis.
No, we're going to see if
you can also weave together
the knowledge.
So an example would be, if
I were to ask you, OK, I'm
going to give you a PES.
So let's see, here would be
like a question about a PES
question.
So here's a PES diagram.
And here I'm going to
draw, I'm going to say, OK,
I give you this PES.
Here we go, let's label
it, three, four, five, six.
We don't need more than that.
OK so, we're going to go,
oh, and a break in the axis.
Now you know all about that.
And we're going to go all
the way up to six here.
And we'll do another break.
We'll go up to two there.
And now this is going
to go up to here.
And you can read off of here.
Remember, with the PES, that's
a relative electron count.
I'm blasting this atom
with enough photon energy
to get all the electrons out.
And then I'm counting
their relative--
I measure the kinetic
energy, I can get the energy.
Oh by the way, this
would be like decreasing,
the way I plotted it before.
And the way we usually plot
PES diagrams is the x-axis
is going down in energy.
Because those are the
1S electrons there.
These would be the 2S.
And these would be the 2P.
And I can keep on going.
So I've got 3S.
Now what do we got here?
We've got 3P, How many?
Four.
OK, good.
OK, a question you might be
asked, what atom is that?
Sulfur.
OK, good.
OK that's sulfur.
So I can answer that
kind of question.
But now, let's take another
concept and weave it in here.
OK, if that's sulfur
and I say, well,
what if I went up to chlorine.
Right so, sulfur has 16.
Sulfur has 16.
And chlorine is 17.
What would this look
like for chlorine?
I gave you this.
Well, you might
say, well, I know,
it's going to just be like this.
But let's go to
the right height.
And now I filled that with
the one more electron.
And so it must be chlorine.
But that's not taking everything
you know into account.
Because you know that
if I go up to chlorine,
I've added a proton.
But I haven't really
done much more
to shield those outer electrons.
And so everything
wants to be closer
to that more positive charge.
So you've got a reflect
that in the PES.
So if I were really going
to say, well now, you know.
You might not even
know quantitatively.
But you know
qualitatively, if I'm
going to draw this
peak for chlorine,
it better be to the
left of that peak.
It's got to move in just
like the orbitals and all
those things we've talked about.
That's the kind of
thing that I mean.
I want you to be able to
synthesize concepts as we
think about exam questions.
Everything is going to shift
over, if you go to chlorine.
Now, on Wednesday, we talked
about Lewis structures.
So let's talk about
Lewis structures more.
Let's suppose I've
got acetaldehyde,
a wonderful toxic compound, H4O.
OK, here is a possible
Lewis structure for this.
All right, let's see, I'm going
to draw the two carbons here.
Here's my oxygen. It's
got some lone pairs, put
another one there, why not.
Hydrogen here, and we got
one more hydrogen there.
What is wrong with this?
Double bond on the
hydrogen. Question
really is, what is
not wrong with this?
I can count three things, right
now, that are wrong with this.
What are they?
Double bond-- this has to
have, remember, these things
need to be happy and
follow their octet.
Octet means for hydrogen, two.
But otherwise, so that's good.
That's good.
That's not good.
OK so, we're not--
is this good?
No, no.
Is that good?
Now, hold on, because OK, but
there's something else that's
fundamentally wrong with this.
Anybody notice?
How many electrons?
This is how you start
a Lewis problem.
How many electrons do I have?
Remember Lewis is all
about the valence.
So I've got 4 times 2, that's 8.
Eight electrons, four electrons
here, and six electrons here,
how many do I have?
So I've got 18 electrons total.
Now what did I put
into this diagram?
So each of these
bonds, remember, a line
is two electrons.
It's a bonding pair.
So I've got 2, 4, 6, 8,
10, 12, 14, 16, 18, 20.
I didn't even get the
electron count right.
I didn't say it's
acetaldehyde two minus.
Wrong number of electrons.
And octets not formed.
There's something else.
There's another
way you can see how
this Lewis structure is wrong.
How is that?
What else did we
learn on Wednesday?
Really important concept.
Formal charge.
Formal charges are
all over the place.
Lowest not lowest formal charge.
Now, when I say lowest,
I mean closest to zero,
because that is what gives
you the most stable structure,
as we talked about on Wednesday.
You can see this, formal charges
here are all over the place.
So the formal charge
on this carbon is--
OK so, you go the number
of valence electrons
of the free atom
minus dots minus 6.
So 4 minus 1, 2, 3,
so that's plus 1.
Oh, 6 minus 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So that would be minus 1.
So this is not a
good Lewis structure
for all of these reasons.
The right Lewis structure
would look something like this.
Very easy fix.
And C, and here you go.
And now, you can check
all of these things
that we just talked about.
You can check the formal charge.
You can check the total charge.
I could've taken two
electrons off of here.
And it still would
have been wrong.
But this is the right
Lewis structure,
because we satisfy all the
things that we talked about
on Wednesday.
OK, good, now, as I mentioned,
there is one other concept oh--
The last concept that
will not be on the exam,
oh, but it could be on
exam two, I don't know,
is the last concept
about Lewis structures
that's very important.
And it's what
happens when you have
structures that look similar.
If I look at all
these things, number
of electrons, octets
forming, formal charges,
these look good.
These both look good.
And so the question is,
which one of them is right?
And this gets into
this concept that I
want to teach you, which
is called resonance.
And just to define resonance,
I'll put that on the board.
These are called
resonance structures.
OK now, resonance, when
referring to Lewis structures,
the way I want you
to think about it
is that it describes
delocalization.
I'm going all caps,
delocalization, why not?
I'm not shouting it.
I'm just saying it's
an important concept.
Describes delocalization
of electrons in molecules.
So in the case of ozone,
which is something
we broke apart and talked about,
we talked about ozone already,
in the case of ozone,
now, what's happening?
Well if I draw the
ozone molecule the way--
if I draw it the
way one of those
is, so I'll draw it the way
the left hand picture is,
like this.
And O and,
I'm not talking about shape.
No shape yet.
[INAUDIBLE] I don't know.
Next week, shape.
This week, no shape.
OK, hold on.
Now, if I look at this
molecule, this is a double bond.
There's more electrons
on this bond than here.
And what we know about
that is that that's going
to make that bond stronger.
And those atoms are
going to be closer.
So this length would actually
be around 1.2 angstroms.
And this one would
be around 1.5ish.
But see, and now, you say,
well, maybe it's the other one.
1.2 over here 1.5 over there.
But now, it take ozone,
and I can measure it.
I can measure
those bond lengths.
And I do that.
And when I do that, what I find
is that it's neither of these.
But in experiment, the
bond length is 1.3.
And it's the same.
It's not different.
So what is happening?
Physically, what is
happening is delocalization.
And remember, electrons
do things to be happy.
Happiness means lowering the
energy of the whole system.
And so what these
electrons realize,
what these extra two electrons
here realize is well, OK,
I couldn't make this bond
short and that bond long.
But maybe if I delocalize
across the whole molecule,
maybe if I do that,
I can be happier.
Meaning I can be in
a lower energy state.
And that is what
resonance talks about.
That is what it tells us about.
It tells us when I have
these different states that
look equivalent,
that the molecule
essentially,
pictorially, is going
back and forth between them
so fast that it's an average.
That it's a delocalization.
Now, the way that we think
about this in terms of our Lewis
structures is by having
one resonant form
and another resonant form.
OK now, hold on.
So, here OK, let's do
this, and this, and double
bond on this side, good.
Chemists are very particular
about how you use arrows.
And you have to be very
careful in chemistry.
But here's a case where
they really like the arrow.
And they really like curvy
arrows in particular.
And what the curvy
arrow shows you
is what happened
to the electrons.
So it's really just
a representation
of where the electrons went
to get from one resonance
structure to another,
how they changed.
But it can be, actually,
helpful to understand
whether you really have
a resonance structure
and what's happened.
So for example, in
this case, these
are the two resonance
structures for ozone.
OK so, what happened?
Well, to get from this structure
to this structure, you can see,
what's happened is that you
can imagine this lone pair has
gone onto that bond.
And this bond, where am I?
This lone pair has
gone onto this bond.
OK, so I've made a double
bond to get to there.
And I've made the double
bond here to get to there.
Now what's missing?
Well, I've got to make the
other lone pair appear here
from this bond.
So you can look at your
resonance structures
and realize that
that also happened.
And you can look over here,
and I've got three lone pairs
on that one.
So the only way to get
that would have been,
let's try draw these over here
to make room, if that happened.
Those curvy arrows
help us just see
how the changes in the electrons
happened in these resonance
structures.
But the way to really
think about this,
and this is why I wanted
to capitalize this word,
is that the actual structure
is a combination of these.
So let's see, I'll do this.
And the way you would
write the actual structure
would be like this.
OK, this, and this, and
this, and dashed lines, oh.
And this is called the
resonant hybrid structure,
Resonant hybrid.
It's a mixture of
the structures.
And it shows, with the dashed
lines, the delocalization.
And if you want to be complete
about this resonance structure
concept, if you
want to be complete,
then you would also
count formal charges.
And so you would see that
the formal charge-- let
me make sure I get this right.
So over here, we've got what?
6 minus 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So the formal charge
here was minus 1.
The formal charge here,
6 minus 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So that's plus
one in the middle.
And the formal charge here
is 6 minus 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So that's zero.
And over here, I'm not going
to do the counting again,
it's the same.
But the zeros and the minus ones
have switched, as you can see.
Now, in the resonant hybrid
structure, what's happened--
notice these are the
two Lewis structures.
So you do have formal charge.
Formal charges are not zero
everywhere, but that's OK.
This is the best you can do.
But you've got the two
that are equivalent.
And they go back and forth.
And in this case,
the way you would
draw that is that you would
have the plus is still there,
but now you're sort of sharing
the formal charge on the ends.
So if you want to
think about this
in terms of formal charge--
notice something
about formal charge.
I did not add or take
away charge, in this case.
I got it added up.
The addition of
all formal charges,
by the definition
of formal charge,
must be equal to the charge
on the molecule, must be.
So if the molecule is neutral,
then the formal charge
must add up to zero, which
it does, does, and it does.
Good way to check your work.
OK so, we can go further.
So that's the
concept of resonance.
And I did it, as I like
to do, kind of slowly.
And now I will give
you another example.
But I'm not going to go
through it as slowly.
And but oh, let's ask this
question, so if I had--
OK so, here's two other cases.
Now, this one we're going
to get through quickly.
Is this a resonance structure?
And I'm going to give you
the answer, the answer is no.
And the reason is that
resonance structures only
involve the curvy arrow
motion of electrons.
The curvy arrows showing us
how electrons might change
in this, but not of atoms.
Notice I cannot get from here
to here without moving an atom.
That's not a
resonance structure.
That is not a
residence structure.
So we're done with that.
And we can put, well, let's
put a little thing here.
Only change location of
electrons, not atoms.
Let's keep this separate.
Not atoms.
But now, we get to
another one, where
we didn't change the
location of atoms,
but we did change the
location of electrons.
And you can see the
structure up there.
And I won't do this, because
I just did it for ozone,
but you can go through
this yourself and show,
with curvy arrows,
what's happening
between these structures.
These are three
resonance structures.
resonance structures
And you can see how they go.
So you can see, like here,
I had that extra lone pair
on the oxygen, that might have a
curvy arrow to here to give you
the double bond there.
But as I did that,
in order for carbon
to keep its formal charge,
I had to do something
with this double bond.
And so this is how you think
about resonance structures.
And just to give you
the final for that one,
just show you what
it would look like.
Once you've got the
hybrid structure,
it would look
something like this.
So there, there, and oxygen
with its two lone pairs,
and oxygen with its two lone
pairs, and the delocalized
electrons.
And then you've got your charge.
And this would be minus
2/3, minus 2/3, minus 2/3.
Notice on these
three oxygen atoms,
notice that, again, the
formal charge adds up
to the charge on the molecule.
There it is.
Charge on the molecule,
that's a 2 minus.
This is CO3 2 minus.
Formal charge adds up to the
charge on the molecule, good.
OK, one more example,
because now we're
going to combine this and learn
one other really important
concept about Lewis structures.
Let's see if this, OK.
So here's an example--
do I have this up here?
No.
Here's an example, what if
I had the thiocyanate ion?
This is a favorite.
So this is CNS minus.
Might as well write the
name here, thiocyanate.
This is a favorite for
demonstrating concepts
about Lewis.
And you'll see why in a minute.
Because first I'm going
to draw a Lewis structure.
This is a minus, so it's an ion.
First I'm going to draw
a Lewis structure that
seems to make sense.
But then as you'll see, there
are resonant Lewis structures
that also seem to make sense.
So I need to use some
of the concepts we've
learned to figure it out.
So if I draw this, let's
see, I'm going to draw three.
So N, triple bond, C, sulfur,
lone pairs, lone pair.
Or I could have N double bond C,
double bond sulfur, lone pair,
lone pair.
Or try to squeeze this in
underneath, so that you can,
put it here.
N, three lone pairs, single
bond C, triple bond sulfur.
Now, these are
resonance structures.
I can get them by
drawing my curvy arrows
and moving electrons around.
And so you might say,
well, is this not just
going to be an average.
Are these electrons
delocalized according
to their resonance structures.
But see, once we start
thinking about formal charge,
we get more insight.
So the formal charge
here is minus 2.
5 minus 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7 minus 2.
Here it's zero.
And here it's plus 1.
Sulfur 6 minus 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So that looks pretty bad, a
large formal charge minus two.
OK over here, oh, I didn't
draw the lone pairs,
sorry about that.
Here's two lone pairs here.
We will not mess up the
electron count again today.
And so here, the formal
charge, let's see,
this one would be minus one.
And in here, it's zero.
And over here, it's zero.
That looks better.
According to my
rules on Wednesday,
this looks like a more
stable structure than that.
So even though
it's resonant, I'm
going to say that's
probably not going
to be part of the most stable
ground state structure.
But let's look at this last one.
Zero, and over
here, I've got zero,
and over here,
I've got minus one.
What do we do?
There's one last point
that we need to learn.
And it has to do with
the formal charges.
And it's a general rule in
writing Lewis structures.
And that is that, let's
see if I can fit it here,
because it's very
relevant to here,
that atoms with the negative
formal charge should be--
I'm not going to
fit it here-- should
be on the more electronegative
ion, electroneg atom, not
ion, atom.
So let's take a look
and see what this means.
Let's understand it, first.
I just wrote something down.
Let's make sure
we understand it.
So atoms with the
negative formal charge
should be on more
electronegative atoms.
That kind of makes sense, right?
Because remember what our
definition of electronegativity
is.
Electronegativity is
the desire of an atom
to bring bonded
pairs towards itself.
Remember, and it makes a
molecule polar, polar covalent,
for example, maybe ionic.
But anyway, it's
that desire to bring
bonded pairs towards itself.
So if an atom has a
negative formal charge,
then you think,
well, that should
be on the more
electronegative atom.
Because the negative
formal charge means
it's got a little
bit extra charge
compared to when it was free.
And so if you look
at this, oh, now you
need to know
electronegativities,
something that we know.
The electronegativity of
nitrogen, so chi, remember,
of nitrogen is around 3.0.
And chi for sulfur
is around 2.5.
And that tells us that this
is the ground state structure.
All from the concepts
we already know.
Now, at the same time, the atoms
that are more electropositive
would want to have positive
formal charges, in general.
So the same rule
applies the other way.
OK now.
So that's the last part
of Lewis structures
that I want you to know about.
And it all ties together.
You can see
resonance, this is why
this is such a great example,
you can think about resonance.
And could you move
electrons around
and get different structures?
Yes, but then those aren't
actually equivalent,
because they have very
different formal charges.
And then two of them had kind
of similarish formal charges,
but one is more stable
because of that.
Now why does this matter?
And I'm going to tell you an
example of why this matters.
I'm talking about
delocalization to stabilize.
And I'm talking about how the
actual structure of a molecule
isn't this rigid two bonds
here, one bond there,
that's not what that
says, but it was in ozone.
But it's this shared
equivalent bonds
where the electron is shared
and the whole system is lowered.
Now, there is one molecule where
this is very much important
and dictates all of
its chemical behavior.
And that's benzene.
And back in the day, in
the 1930s, oh, by the way,
Pauling, electronegativity
scale. we
talked about him on Wednesday.
But back in the day, they
didn't know what benzene was.
They could kind of
measure some things.
But none of it worked.
And Pauling wrote a number
of structural formulae
have been proposed for
benzene, but none of them
is free from very
serious objections.
The way they wrote stuff.
Look at these
shapes for benzene.
If we don't know the right
shape and why you have the right
shape for benzene, then
we cannot understand all
of the mega amounts of organic
chemistry that we do with
benzene.
So this is what's
happening with benzene.
You have these two structures
that benzene actually averages
over.
These are resonance structures.
Back in the day, they called
them Kekulé structures
because Kekulé, as you can see,
was kind of close and thought
about this as well.
These are resonance structures.
It totally dictates
the chemistry
of benzene, which then leads
to massive amounts of things
that we do with benzene.
Because with benzene,
and this is just,
we don't need to look
at this in detail,
this is an example of a few out
of almost unlimited variations
of benzene that we can make.
Because we can take one
of those hydrogen atoms
and put something on
it, or two places.
And each time we do that,
we get a different material,
a different molecule
that gives us
different properties
and different uses.
But all of this, even
though we draw it, still
with those lines, we know
that inside, it's delocalized.
It's delocalized.
Well, it might change
once you add stuff to it.
But by itself here, by itself
here, it's delocalized.
And that sets up the
properties of benzene.
Now OK, let's go
a little farther.
So I like these last two here.
Naphthalene, now, you
can keep on going,
and keep adding
benzenes, and we're
going to get somewhere
that I really love.
This is getting me excited.
Oh, look I'm going
to add one there.
I'm just going to
keep adding benzene.
Now I could stay here, oh,
don't get benzene wrong.
I can keep going.
And if I kept going, I
might get sheets of benzene
that are now called graphene.
And if I stack those
up, I've got graphite.
I've got graphite.
That's what graphite is.
It's these very large
sheets of benzene.
Now, there are two
very well-known phases
of pure carbon.
One is diamond.
And the other is graphite.
Does anybody know which
one is more stable?
How many people think graphite?
How many people think
diamonds are forever?
I'm giving you guys some advice,
especially like, you're out,
and maybe you're out on a date.
And it's the weekend.
And there's a candle.
And you've talked
about combustion.
And you've written that down.
And you talked about how
long you have in that room,
because you know about oxygen
and the limiting reagent
that it's either
you or the candle.
We talked about that.
We also talked about how
you need your periodic table
on that date.
And how you may need
your spectroscope,
because they might give
you an LED candle instead.
You need to talk about LEDs.
And I'm not saying that all of
these conversations involving
knowledge you
gained in this class
will lead to this
place of seriousness,
but it could lead to engagement.
It could.
And now, some people
when they get engaged,
one person buys
the other a ring.
And sometimes that
involves this material.
My point to you right now
is when you go to the store,
maybe it's Tiffany's,
maybe it's somewhere else,
and you buy that ring,
ask for a warranty.
And make sure it's about 100,000
years, because after that time,
that ring is going to
turn into graphite,
because graphite is the
lowest most energetically
stable form of carbon.
So I'm just, again,
always trying to help.
But this is the most
stable form of carbon.
And it's a bunch of
benzene, but repeated.
Not benzene, the
hydrogens are gone.
It's just pure
graphene, but repeated
in these beautiful rings.
And when we come
back to hybridisation
and molecular orbitals, which
we'll start after exam one,
you'll see other
beautiful properties
of structures like this.
By the way, speaking of seeing,
you can see this material.
What are you throwing at this
material to see it like that?
Not light, not photons,
you're throwing electrons.
I just came across this
the other day in Wired,
New microscope shows the
quantum world in crazy detail.
They took electrons
and they shine it
on these little particles
of platinum and iron.
And they're able to literally
see every single atom as they
break apart the particle.
By just throwing
electrons at it,
they say, the transmission
electron microscope
was designed to break records.
Using its beam of
electrons, scientists
have glimpsed many types of
viruses, et cetera, et cetera.
They got down to 0.4 angstrom
resolution in that work.
It's a beautiful thing.
And being able to
see these materials
has revolutionized what
we can do with them.
Diamonds and graphite makes
me, when I talk about graphite,
I get excited.
Now I'm working on my arm here.
So I got to go up that way.
And I got to go this way.
All right, hold on, hold
on, let's go that way.
Now, wait a second.
I'm very excited.
Oh wait, there was
a lot of noise.
I tried.
I got to work on my arm.
It's such a beautiful material.
Too excited.
We'll have more.
Now I don't mean to
bring us down after why
this matters and excitement.
But here's the thing,
if there's one thing
you know about
chemistry by now, it's
that chemistry lives
in the fast lane.
And what I mean is, they
know about the rules.
And they also know they're
meant to be broken.
And Lewis and octets
are no exception.
And so there are exceptions
to Lewis's octet rule.
And I'll give you a
couple of examples.
And it has to do
with the concepts
that we've been talking about,
but in particular, like boron.
Boron trifluoride, well,
that one, you could draw it.
If you wanted to, you
could draw it like this.
And let's see, here, F,
and you can do this, F.
But the problem
with this is then,
when you look at the formal
charges, you've got a minus 1
there and a minus 1 there.
And so actually, what
this structure does,
is boron is like, you
know what, I'm flexible.
I don't need my eight.
I can be OK with six.
As long as you keep
sharing, fluorine atoms,
as long as you keep
sharing those electrons
so we can make these three
covalent bonds all equivalent,
I'm OK.
And so this is actually--
and you can see,
the formal charges on all
the atoms here is zero.
This is actually the
stable structure,
even though boron does
not, this does not
satisfy the octet rule.
Chemistry, breaking the rules.
So boron is said to be happy.
Boron can be, what is called in
this world, electron deficient.
And by the same token,
you can go the other way.
And sulfur likes to go the other
way, because sometimes sulfur,
so there we have
sulfur tetrafluoride.
So I'm using the
same external atom,
but sulfur also prefers
to look like this
and to have one extra
lone pair there.
And now we can go like this,
and like that, and like that.
And so what sulfur will
do, oh boy, lots of dots,
and so what sulfur
will do is it will
form what's called an expanded
octet, expanded octet.
And this will become
also, a little bit--
we'll sort of understand
this also a little bit more
once we look at shapes.
Shapes are going to
play an important role
in molecular stability.
But for now, I just wanted
you to know that there
are exceptions to the rules.
And in particular, as you
go beyond the first couple
of rows, so you go down
in the period table,
you do find atoms more
willing, like sulfur,
to have an expanded octet
in order to reach the lowest
energy state.
Now, in the last two
minutes, I come back to this.
Let's just bring
it all back home
around Lewis, and around
electronegativity,
and around all these
covalent bonding concepts.
And what I want
to leave you with
is what was kind
of the point, part
of the point of your goody bag.
Which is, I wanted you to get
your hands on these materials
so you could touch and
feel the differences
and see that actually it's
the properties at the end that
are also very important for
determining what a material is.
So you can make rules like
electronegativity difference
less than 1.6 is going
to be polar covalent
or non-polar covalent,
or greater than two,
it's probably ionic.
But at the end of
the day, you've
got to come back to properties.
I'll put up a
slide showing this,
but ionic solids
are hard, brittle,
and solid at room temperature.
Covalent solids can be
gases, liquids, or solids.
Covalent solids have
a low melting point.
Ionic solids are typically high.
Covalent solids are
poor conductors.
Ionic ones are usually
insulators as a solid.
This is what you
need to also do.
You can't just go by one metric.
You got to look
at the properties.
It's what Mendeleev did.
And it's what chemists have
always done to make progress.
OK so, on that note,
have a great weekend.
And see you at the exam.
[CROWD NOISE]